o olá boa tarde não é necessariamente
verdade o fio catarina eu pretendo
acabar a conversar convosco tenho medo
não preencher os 18 minutos eu fiz um
t-rex tá oito anos atrás em barcelos e
jurei que nunca mais quando viu o vídeo
sentindo um pouco na lula tá saponinas
vestibular imenso e a pessoa que não
gostei da figura e daí eu evitaria ir
até vou ter em quando algumas
dificuldades também não não quer dizer
que não vou lá de alguns vai acontecendo
eu gosto partilhar as minhas
experiências mas receita será guimarães
por duas razões esta é a minha cidade
construída no país gosto imenso
guimarães ela vem cá muitas vezes
almoçar fazer um copo usar inclusivas
fizemos aqui uma vez que eu tive a pena
que não continuar o primavera colado
numa primeira edição a afeta anos atrás
i perguntou a opção tenho uma relação de
afeto muito grande com com esta cidade e
depois o tendo quando aquela me
convenceu o tema ou tudo ou nada então
eu resolvi contar a história da edição
de 2004 é do festival um festival que
vocês conhecem o parede para que começa
precisamente em 1993 e sempre foi um
festival que viveu com algumas
dificuldades de viver com os possível da
da câmara municipal de paredes de coura
sem patrocinadores representado duas
frases marcantes no festival a primeira
em 1999 quando do podemos pela primeira
vez mais de 10 mil pessoas que foi até
um bocadinho assustador a todos repente
começam a ficar autocarros forma
desorganizada com jogar uma coisa
receber planeada conosco e
e ele lembra-me de inclusive a chorar de
metal mas também criar o bastante para
quentinho para dormir a cerca de 300 mil
pessoas no campismo e não havia espaço
para isso sim para contar essa história
mas depois vai mesmo com o tudo ou nada
não levava obrigatoriamente haverá
edição de 2004 que foi uma sugestão
mítica com os motores e que subiu
rigorosamente durante uma semana mas
choveu torrencialmente portanto foi um
festival que começou a ser montado
debaixo de chuva e acabou de debaixo de
chuva né
o festival que teria a cerca de 10 mil
pessoas acabou com 3.000 com pessoas
este a roupa interior com pessoas com
alana pelos lados quando foi uma
catástrofe eu vou contar já essa
história do jornal público mas logo a
tirar o festival a primeira página do
jornal público só para terem uma ideia
era não subir a gente está lá 99 anos
assim eu ainda de verdade eu posso te
pode também começar a estar ao contrário
porque é lembro perfeitamente uma
tristeza a generalizada por de repente
era preciso continuar com um festival
tínhamos o chefe da segurança a dizer
que era absurda de fazê-lo a tínhamos o
responsável da empresa do palco que
dizia que pode haver desabamento de
terras e o próprio pelo que posso ver
tínhamos 13 opção a dizer podia haver um
curso vitor tínhamos as autoridades de
todas é com competência na matéria a
dizerem que tínhamos cancelar
bom e nós estávamos um pouco devido à
grande para aqui porque dizem eu falei
com o vítor também já fez ter que era
aquela um dos sócios do real trade parei
agora não é porque a ficar presidente da
câmara e ele disse-me que outros vão ser
andar lá tua passagem tô ficando nervosa
presente aguardando lá para o mas então
essa essa repente tínhamos toda a gente
também ao envolvido no festival a contra
a continuidade do mês nós próprios temos
algumas dúvidas nas eu até que os mais
insistentes estava aqui oficial tenho
que fazer porque de repente temos ali
três quatro mil pessoas foram os que
restaram estão ali de baixo no império
vai ter chuva e portanto uma região que
o festival do continente mas lembro
corretamente estamos divididos houve uma
reunião tensa aonde oitenta por cento
das pessoas estavam pessoal não devia
continuar e 39 estavam que eu tinha de
continuar e a verdade é que o festival
de fez debaixo desta
a intentar só para ter uma ideia o povo
dezenas de carros que foram parar para
as oficinas por caíram pedras de granizo
desta mãe que sempre foi um ano
terrorífico eu lembro perfeitamente e já
vamos ao tudo ou nada ao tempo
corretamente para casa no fim do
festival foi isso não tenho não tenho
vergonha da costura aí eu só não ser
vezes e as costurar faz bem as
pendências o que sentimos um prejuízo
acumulado tínhamos alguns bens poucos
nós tínhamos nossos pais imigrantes e
descendentes adivinhava um ano de muito
prejuízo instantes antes de ir para a
cama estivemos a conversar e achamos que
oficial que tinha tinha chegado a tempo
tanto que não íamos conseguir conciliar
o produto interno com os prejuízos que
venham a de anos anteriores o presente
imaginam a melhores tenistas não-sócios
quando quando nós fomos deitar deitar
esperam vai assim da manhã e eu não
consigo
e como ela já tinha um acordo com o meu
vizinho da frente não trazia todos os
dias os jornais e eu acordava em cada
dia do festival e operacionais e então é
isso que eu vejo essa primeira página do
público portanto ainda tem ver a luz do
dia deitado debaixo da grande tempere
uma semana inteira poder e abre a porta
pernas jornais a primeira viagem logo do
público e é a mais certo é não exclui as
instalar 99 anos podem procurar anda de
2004 que 1920 agosto essa mensagem
existe e e eu já estava triste diz uma
tristeza ainda maior porque quer dizer
se não estava assim há 99 anos que vai
com certeza manhã desta semana e abro a
persiana do quarto e entra um raio do
sol não coisa ainda acreditava
lembrei-me do lembra do que fez algumas
estrangeiro do alberto carinhoso quando
passeava pela praia e bater um raio de
sol e no mixto delírio loucura mata uma
pessoa foi assim que me senti vamos
conhecer aquele aquele raio só porque
como é que é possível depois de uma
semana
eu acho importante de uma semana tão
complicada o diabo piraquara descer do
salto mesmo dia vamos lá então
conversamos e na cabeça para a ideia não
há nada a fazer escrever é uma história
bonita nas como todas as histórias
bonitas acho que só tem o seu fim e
estávamos mesmo pedido acabar com
festival claro que o tempo cura tudo eu
sempre haverá mais que suficiente não
temos continuar a fazer também era o
único que moravam em couro que estava
interesse para a tempo inteiro à como
instalando já tivemos alguns telefonemas
e vamos ajuntar e pedimos ou tudo ou
nada vamos morrer vamos morrer com
dignidade e fizemos aquela super edição
de 2005 com aquele fire tipos de metais
o período racionais o kaiser ser tanto
de saúde são tantos que eu tenho esquece
de alguns
o que realmente eu pessoalmente esse
festival e o ano nos outros ou nada que
salvou e trouxe até aqui o que hoje o
vodafone paredes de coura aqui tenho
orgulho em discutivelmente um festival
que que mudou a forma de ouvir música em
portugal e um festival que não se faz
nos vemos tempo por favor parece muito
fácil para fazer um festival em paredes
de coura mas a verdade é que agora uma
terra pequena onde responde lá hoje
totalmente encontra um pouco os
restaurantes abertos para para almoçar
ou jantar portanto cálculo de todos os
conselhos da interioridade hoje parece
fácil fazer um federal no que foi
realmente muito muito difícil nós nessa
questão de 2004 tínhamos um patrocinador
é que estava a pensar no varejo por
causa de entrar em um novo no corpo
sentiremos mais e sindicato não
transmissão é o quanto podemos de isso
eu pedi para por em trem passarem atende
eu não vou ver então se eu fico nervoso
assim vocês não receberam com as imagens
é
e nós temos a sua assinatura em 2014 que
existiu por cento é atribuição 2005
lutas do nada fazer uma com esses
grandes nomes um super cartaz ainda hoje
aspecto dos melhores alinhamento alguma
vez feitos cá em portugal têm qualquer
possível cliente foi um suicídio a queda
d'água que devem ficar bem e não
impossível ao agora não deu nenhum agora
não esquece pediu uns 20000 horas uma
estrutura grande como nossas apagar o
telefone na altura as contratações ainda
eram quase todas feitas ao telefone para
estrangeiros mas já foram até que dá uma
nova dimensão o festival foi eleito pelo
ao país um dos nossos lá toda obra foi
capa do país avaliem funciona com sido
um dos melhores tens festivais do mundo
o da guarda em também fez boas
referências ao festival e de repente
toda a gente queria saber o que se
passava numa terra em tão pequena para
ter uma constelação tão grande estrela
e acabou ainda estão 2005 a um
completamente os metalizados ou a bandas
adoraram assistir ao festival aliança os
anéis não acordaram ss esta edição e
neste ano não sei se alguém foi o por
esta número ser o ficar lista dos
danados não é disso que lembrava
perfeitamente daquela anfiteatro e até
conta uma história engraçada porque
conheceu um detalhe das igualmente que o
único é respondeu o frio foi uma estados
que eles não são muito engraçada mas
parece parece essa coisa não tem gente
que passa na frente teatro e que acordem
recentemente em uma entrevista poder
grau se lembrava de pagamento daquele
esse teatro é como o ano passado
presentes repetidos falhas que lembravam
é precisamente a energia do antigo
teatro e da e dá aquele público que nós
temos um público um público diferente na
lama no empenhado ali ajudar no para mim
a melhor estamos sempre o festival
potência não superior comunidade o
festival a bonito acidente região caras
no
e ela atrás era próximo evento porque
não tinha ninguém se feriu no segundo
ganha a fotografar um seguir ninguém
filmar a vencer as pessoas absorver
música e com cara de dimensões mas estão
a fazer um bocadinho não faltam 7
minutos então eu porque eu queria
perguntar a
é mas a verdade é que essa edição é esse
arroz parte do tudo ou nada só vou
festival da social tem uma história de
peça oficial mulheres de 2005 só deu
mais uma vez transferidos o que tem que
foi lá no fundo ok vamos arriscar vamos
provavelmente não é a melhor até que não
temos patrocínio mas vamos ganhar uma
nova vida dignidade e se morremos
morremos morremos morremos que tem
combustível celular a gente estava
lembrar da última edição das preces
foram nós vamos trabalhar para a
construção civil durante toda a vida
para pagar o prejuízo acumulado mas
vamos ter uma história bonita ver a
vontade era felizmente a partir dessa
edição apareceram outros patrocínios
aliás tem gostar muito curiosa que posso
contar porque falta realmente entende
vai terminar diferente a mesma coisa é
muito no ano a seguir em 2006 nós
fazemos um festival chamado logo a gente
sentada continuamos a fazer agora em
braga então acho que o futebol tem ou
não
a todos aqueles que fazem no país
estávamos a fazer o festival para gente
sentada e ele é um carro estacionar e eu
simpático como sempre estou ajuda a
senhora estacionar o carro que me
pergunta a você vem ao festival e tem
alguma coisa que eu considero a consegue
eu vou estar de folga que é um artista
que eu gosto muito de que estava lá é
que eu gostava de trazer um dia outra
vez aparece para pode ser que fazer este
ano a rádio consegue vou estar de folga
e começamos a falar um bocadinho e eu
falo precisamente o que ficará
computador lado explique o que fazer o
festival depois disso não deve ser falar
seus patrocínios ou de um banco com
outros organizadores palavras que vão as
coisas não te esqueças das dificuldades
pois agora imagino eu explicar a senhora
agora mas nós no interior imagina nem
parece que a hora que é uma terra
pequena assim mas o pessoal tem precisa
pois tem preciso mas nós realmente os
patrocinadores tão preguiçosos que tem
tudo o que é que saia de lisboa e do
porto edifícios aplicativo 500 reuniões
com pessoas
e a ele é muito lindo sim no interior
tem vaquinhas próximas colocar lisboa
conhecimento essa forma de pensar é
completamente diferente ainda bem o
facebook ou nesse sentido porque era
realmente era realmente muito complicado
mas a história é continuar falar com a
senhora e de repente eu digo 10
dificuldades não ter um patrocinador a e
ele disse posso tentar ajudar os vezes
aparecia nas histórias ouvir 50 não era
muita gente não tinha dito poderiam
ajudar e depois quando quando se fala de
um lenço onça está retendo a falar do
grandes vegas mas não tinha nada estava
disposto a a abaixar ao mínimo uma
decisão foi a verdade é que não ser
apenas um carro conseguir sensível da
neurais para a edição deste ano do
festival no dia a seguir assim ele
ligou-me a dizer não tenho aqui um isso
aí aparece a muita gente que diz a
primeira parece acreditar que aparece
precisamente através desse senhor que
entretanto tinha uma empresa angolana
que via torrent em angola
e na altura queria ter vestindo em
portugal durante a pesquisa deve estar
associada a algum evento e pois assim
conseguimos a rita foi um anos ou ele
estendendo de torcedor mas também ajudou
a sustentar o festival desse ano nós
temos o processo de 2005 tínhamos uma
boa imprensa temos um público satisfeito
tínhamos alguns agentes internacionais é
para trazer bandas em 2006 mas falta
vamos fazer a mente um patinho pautava a
fazer a gestão diária de uma empresa com
a falta de patrocínios fizemo então essa
não consegui certo e a partir daí a
partir nunca mais faltam condicionador
depois o pessoal ah entendi pois temos
uma relação muito sólida com com a
vodafone o cabo o tudo ou nada também eu
também pode ficar aqui porque quando
aparece a vodafone a aparece através de
um amigo meu quem tanto se tornou sócio
que o josé eduardo martins alguns devem
conhecer porque está ligada à política e
à televisão pois é de lado era meu amigo
era e e e eu pedi muito para
o contacto conhecimentos para nós
tivemos várias fases havia uma fase aqui
vamos a lisboa do carro o intervalo para
o português e inglês nos filmes com isso
e toda a gente está começa a cabeça
funciona portanto é preciso conhecer as
pessoas certas realidade o que ela
arranja a vodafone entre em contato com
a vodafone por isso que não estava
interessada em eventos fora de lisboa e
do porto e ao meio que vem para o zé
eduardo a ser infelizmente não dá nada
outra ser lando referência desculpa não
ter até tenho pena porque a paciência
emprego escorra a partir daí eu que dei
no e-mail e disse deixa-me ser o seu
melhor em paredes 480 ar agarrar isto
não pode ser que eu já disse que não é
certeza eu entro em contato com o pedro
chamada as coisas estão nas ruas não vi
também direto da máquina a vapor e dele
e pedro então tá se atua em paredes qual
é a tem algum carinho de varejo fora
porque acredito não então redondo porque
opinião e pensar fora da caixa
e para de lisboa e do porto e ele eu
tenho que não tenho nessa pena mas
também não haverá e depois tem uma
administração e cinzenta nem sempre é
fácil explicar e eu ofereço de o palco
vodafone tempo tem que ter o cálculo da
tarde que na altura é para vender um
presente agora na minha era oferecido
por 20.000 larga fibras que o paciente
não só quer bem assim desaparece
corporal sendo autores ai quem vai
aparecer a ficar gostar e percebe a
dimensão ou parece que era planeta o
mesmo teste acho que dispositivos mais
bem organizados no país aqueles que mais
se preocupa com as pessoas a construir
os que não deixam marcas fritar mas é
preciso haver em algum problema que as
pessoas não seriam dos dois caminhos
agora que o pedro vai lá e fica
completamente fascinado com o festival
não consegui convencê-la sim pagando
quase nada aquele pessoal hoje a roda
fone gastar alguns milhões na portugal e
é muito engraçado porque a primeira
reunião que eu vou aí eu parasse
eu tava na toda a primeira reunião que
eu vou aí roubar de falar um bocadinho
disso tudo o que é que eu
estrangeirismos aquela aquela aquela
aquela conversa só eu já que preferem os
outros e apresentaram um um cartão e foi
coisa que nós nunca mentimos até a livro
é que alguém quisesse um cartaz que nós
apresentamos um cartaz com lenço de
viana do castelo que eu achei as
pensamento horrível importantes eles
falavam estrangeirismos eu resolvi eu
resolvi ele sabe falar em português eu
lembro me seguir que antes naquele dia
eu disse qualquer coisa nem quero voltar
a ver isso com estes olhos que a terra
há-de comer não tão provocatório e
percebe que criou se ali um clima ele a
explicar o festival está sempre esses
programas podia fazer sem nova york
podia fazer um par scud a fazer em
copenhague apresento até para a marca
era mal estar na direcionada aquilo para
a região de viana do castelo mas estou
dizer que agora em tanto tempo fazemos
agora fazem 30 segundos para dizer muito
rapidamente centro antiga mostrar para
outras regiões e estava eu contra uma
é a primeira conta conquistar um
patrocinador foi o maior que algumas
acidentes 13 fora mas também ou contra
uma mesa de 12 pessoas sozinho não sei
porque assim foi a tua mensagem a dizer
que não que não era aquela forma de
comunicação e que não lembro conhecer
aquele seu até sem o cartaz não é
reconhecer que a gritar que não é um não
ia permitir que eles folclorizado tem
demasiado o festival e tenta impor as
novas regras que não queríamos ter
grandes estruturas nem grande
comunicação e a verdade é que o primeiro
ano foi chato e hoje em dia e agora vou
terminar só os eu só vou usar mais 20
segundos a daqui hoje em dia todo
estudos de opinião que são feitos
diariamente são feitos todos os da
opinião no festival todos eles dizem que
a marca sicoob de ano para ano não só a
marca vodafone com uma marca super bock
como como todas as outras estão lá que
nós e aço permitam na colocar nesse dia
e a modesta acho que criamos uma nova
forma de comunicar
e portanto não há não há grande
populares as marcas se comunicam de
forma a subsidiar a e as marcas vamos
razão e é muito bom ouvir de vez em
quando a dizer na vodafone ainda me
lembro da primeira reuniões ainda bem
que eu nunca nunca atendeste e a verdade
essa festival nacional de garra um floco
nunca permitam o palavrão nunca se
prostituiu e importante escrever aqui e
pronto dessa muito obrigado vamos fazer
a